I uh I struggled with this topic for
many years I've been a developer for
maybe like I guess 15 years now and I I
thought maybe I could just gather all
the information that I could find put it
in one one book uh so that the Next
Generation could use bit but anyway so
this is the story of programmers right
automated in 10 hours 21 miles and or a
10 minutes easy solution where
you you know you
use spreadsheets basically I mean now we
have fight in spreadsheets but who know
that that should be is better but uh so
organization wise just like some topics
I just selected a couple topics I'm
sorry about the echo in this room but um
some topics you know like it requires
you a lot of patience for development uh
the word modern is relative so sometimes
it's good sometimes it's you know you
your organization might live in the past
these topics might be like relevant um
or your organization is in the future
which means that's like you do this all
the time and everything is
great but uh so just some disc this is
Zuma opinions right like no Financial
advice no employer stuff this just to
entertain complet like forget everything
that that that you see here it's totally
just uh you know trenches kind of uh
Concepts that you might find I wanted to
run a little poll I know raising your
hand is a little hard but um so this is
this is the canonical sort of uh you
know continuous integration continuous
delivery pipeline world for any sort of
software project and specifically for
data pipelines and I wanted to know if I
don't know if audience would participate
but who has who has a continuous
integration continuous delivery pipeline
for their data reporting for
example okay okay so keep your hands up
if you have two systems one is the
continuous integration world where
you're run
specifically uh you know stag in test
that won't break the company and on the
right you have continuous
delivery that will uh push stuff to
actually
stakeholders we lost everybody at this
point can't be the can't be the case
Okay so okay we have two two left now
inside continuous integration side who
has like a a test data management ideas
to generate test data test test tic
effect and and reference data right we
probably lost 90% again fine and so at
this point forget it after that it's
just manual stuff world so you're going
to have test results from your pipeline
saying you know my my tests that I have
about my pipeline ran correctly I need
my test data reference data artifact and
the workflow kind of code that runs that
now automatic trigger that will trigger
something on my continuous delivery side
where I'm going to click a button says
yes I approve and then magically
everything is going to flow into the
production system so this is sort of
what's been kind of preached over on the
I guess like the single transaction
world but for data
pipelines um you 10ex the difficulty in
a way because of the data volumes and
changes in so just po just to
testing in test in the right when you're
building data pipelines and you're just
starting like all of us started right
you have various different problems that
you learned in school in your boot
camp and some of them come from training
right like you know the six we boot camp
a very good accountant became data
scientist uh yeah there is questions
that she's going to get or she's going
to get it's like is this number correct
why is the dashboard not updated with
yesterday's data how come we didn't
catch this bug up
stream the complication is that these
people you know new Engineers don't miss
the big picture of what kind of failures
happen in data pipelines and they find
them on the job so transitive failure
modes are are one of those things so
here in this picture we see like we have
a data bug right on the on the red here
or uh you have a code bug where it
creates like a um like you know the job
completely fails which makes the orange
ones um fail stale so those ones can't
run because Upstream dependencies are
are not ready which makes that these
dashboards are missing data for the
newest data that should that can't be uh
available and then on the other hand you
have data bug and in the top part you
can have silent bad data apis that you
know you you are showing uh in erroneous
data to your toer my point is that you
need some sort of framework so that you
can fix this stuff and fixing existing
code refactoring either the behavior or
the structure of your code is this kind
of you
know in a way maybe 60 to 70% of what we
do um so that's that's one the other bad
lifestyle that I I've seen over my
career is like this is what your life
looks like right you're right you're
coding you're coding for like maybe like
a you know five minute period and you're
like oh this looks great then you're
running bam you let's scan like 100
terabytes of data and then wait for it
for another you know best case maybe 15
minutes if you if you're paying for high
resources and then there is a bug on
step four you get this giant stack tra
that you don't know what to do about you
read the stack tras and uh you know it's
bad for your health right it's better
for your health right you're burning
shared resources you're you have longer
and an average human attention spans and
it's productivity killer right so uh you
end up working at night weekends because
that's when the clusters are not too
busy with your co-workers or production
pipelines right so it's kind of you know
uh quality of life that you you want or
how KB so K back is like I guess
ReDiscover of this driven development
and it's basically this this kind of
testing infrastructure is like a like a
Xanax for you right you rerun something
and you're like you have all this
anxiety am I going to break something
and uh testing is almost like a little
bit of a you
know the closest thing we can get to
anxiety
reliever so the key Point here is that
you want to shorten the
feedback which which most of you right
you you're like okay this is a real
problem I should have I mean I have at
work and um tdd right T tdd for data
scientist or or data pipeline work is
quite the mystery right it's like
writing an acceptance test
for you know like an ml application or
for a dashboard is quite the you know we
don't even have as a like a civilization
sort of a way of defining
it and then in there once you build your
acceptance test then you want to write a
failing test right make the unit test
pass refactor during this red green
Loop and then once that's working you
make an acceptance test
pass local version or whatever you're
developing passes then you checking in
some Source control then you have all
these automated things integration
performance security compliance with
runs then you have a deployment and
monitoring
component and then you're able to accept
newer right this is the promise right
the the promise of this ideas is is that
you have a framework of how to work to
reduce your
anxiety but unfortunately there's like
two camps right either you've never You'
like unaware this is happening that this
exists right I mean I've been in that
camp at the beginning of my career like
you don't know that tdd or like a lot of
people have been thinking about testing
for a while you just like you know focus
on your application it's kind of yeah or
you got you almost got fired for like
delivery right it's like what Tes
you know stakeholders Don't Care Project
managers don't care customers don't care
right they just want to work in
subware um I guess it's not that it's
it's like unusable but it's definitely
like a goal that you know we we should
keep in mind take continuous delivery is
such a you probably heard this term but
it's like Contin deliver is the ability
to get changes of all types including
new features configuration changes bu
fixes experiments into production and
into the hands of user safely quickly
and sustainable way right it's like um
your your um it's all
encompassing and and when a new data
developer you know comes in they hear
this they're like yeah we should use
continue to deliv but it's like maybe
80% 90% of resources that you find
online in training school is about the
single transaction model of of I'm going
to get an input from some system I'm
going to do something to it I'm going to
return it or display
it very few re references that's what
I've been trying to track down in this
book references patterns and uh that are
specific to the data
world so more than one transaction less
than a
bit then you get the objections I don't
like this I don't want to do this it's
too much you know the pipeline they give
me deterministic results yesterday my
test fast today they don't creating the
test data forget I going to replicate
the data ware house n that's you're
you're you're talking crazy so here
recreating the production environment of
where this is going to run on your
laptop I mean yeah okay okay okay okay
then you want to you know so so I guess
the guidance is like you definitely want
to learn about t
CD in in you know if you're not using it
today in a smaller projects in a
cata just to learn about the concepts
there that are related to the
transaction level World and then try to
see how it applies to the also read this
book so I have a couple more ideas in
like I have a couple
chapters then it in terms of types of
tests right like the it's very important
for Thea engineers data scientists to
realize this giant jump that happens
like you're like local okay you know I'm
I'm I'm focused I like to use some unit
test on my on my on my Transformations I
have this composite unit tests okay
three transforms I'm going to call it a
pipeline unit test but then
suddenly running from 30 seconds on my
laptop
to like maybe 10 10 times order
magnitude increase in the waiting time
because as soon as you're going to hit
the network and you're going to rely on
external
resources you know your your uh your
productivity Loop your development Loop
like it just crashes it's like you know
you're um so the guidance there is like
you know you want to break it down again
see if you can generate smaller data
sets uh as much as it fits in your
testing machine uh see if we have budget
for that in your organization as as much
as it fits in your time budget you know
don't like your your coming cycle in
continuous Del World should be less than
five minutes so you should get feedback
on any change that you made in less than
five minutes I I bet run some query some
group by joining T tables bunch of like
lateral explode whatever like you you
you just expect that this is how it's
going be and when you do that you know
that you're gonna
wait then immediately you you fall into
the Trap of B chain work instead of
working on just what you're working on
right now you're like I'm going to wait
anyway 30 minutes but as well put a
longer uh code change so that I can
amortize my my my work so this is the
reality of of the engineer sometimes you
don't have other options but sometimes
you
do this is a diagram of found online I
try to edit it uh it's a kind of semi
famous right small medium large
tests um unfortunately you
know three three fours of your day are
spent in these large tests because
you're just like stuck like uh managing
all these data sets but the but what you
want is is okay okay I have a code base
that only has large tests like how can I
bring it to a medium a Medi
is basically minimal network access
right minimal database access minimal
file system access right so crazy to say
for the engineers minimal external
apis multiprocessing okay on your
development machine and distributed
distributed processing if it's a cluster
job forget it like it jumps directly to
a large so you know don't basically
don't call your your test like unit test
or medium test if you're touching the
network it immediately feels like it's
going to become a large test so you're
going to just just some vocabulary for
you
to I mean I'm I'm skipping around in the
book I have like a couple examples
couple things some something useful
right the the right audit publish
pattern right the right audit publish
pattern you probably use it without
having a name for it but this is what
what it does right your the naive load
uh pattern is that you directly do a
transformation and push it to a
consumer right some some team got got
fired because the financial data they
had errors which lost investors which
made company down scale and act the team
this is just to scare you a little bit
it's not real but but they still don't
know why like unfor so the complication
you know uh so so the stakeholders might
permit this once right like your or dat
a consumer but maybe we can tell the
consumers to to wait 12 hours to give us
some time to run the validation on the
pro table and then notify them if there
is an issue maybe we send an automated
message once our ration finishes so the
guidance right it's like guidance is
like yeah can you just run validation on
your end before pushing data to the to
the pro table Yeah okay do that okay
like how do I organize it I organize you
have a prod table an audit table and a
rejected table so what you do what you
do is you you have uh your
transformation right then you run data
validation you write your output to the
audit
table you do your validation on the
table and then anything that's working
you push it in the prodject table or you
abort the whole data load or you load
the valid part inside the production
table and then you send the reject data
to the rejected table also called dead
dead letter q but in our world it's like
rejected data that we couldn't process
so we can look at it later
right every time you see something in
the rejected data great opportunity to
add a metric right yeah this is this is
something you can use tomorrow at your
job right
yeah dat quality tooling right we care a
lot about data quality tooling when
you're when you're evaluating a data
tool in your work you probably have one
already look for these five items right
you want a you want something that's a
profiler that's able to scan and
generate
expectations it's going to generate
expectations like a machine so you need
to relax them a little bit you have data
expectation stores where you store these
codified expectations you store them you
have these analyzers that are almost
like data jobs also that's going to read
this this expectation scan and publish
whatever metric which we're going to put
in a metric store and then some Quality
Reporting on time if you don't have one
of these characteristics in your current
data quality too that's something to
bring up because for data engineer it's
very useful to have this sort of thing
and I'm like is it good enough this is
the five key kind of pillars of a data
Quality
Tool other things you might need right
you might need a metadata catalog
you might need a lightweight data
exploration tool so that you can find
bugs in your
data you need to be able to build and
operate the data by
line and you set some quality Gates same
idea as the as the audit table you set
some quality Gates completeness
consistency uniqueness timeliness
relevance things like that because
you're going to be in a situation where
in a larger organization you find
competing data analytics data science
teams that have various
like a different uh kind of cycle time
so you're going to be like why is this
taking so long when this te has done the
same thing in two weeks why are you do
why are we doing it in three
months so you ask you talk to the our
team you're going to see that they
invested previously on various kind of
testing tools deployment tools things
like that so you know Ste whatever you
can and include it in your in your in
your
B so have a couple like more kind of
examples of what can be done you know
the code scale versus data scale uh just
like a collection of what the our
community has built so far that's true
then then you have this one you have
this one right you're you are uh you
inherit so inheritance of Thea pipeline
is a big deal where you are and you hire
or you move teams there is a reor and
you are inheriting a data pip and that's
working fine
it's working fine yesterday just fine
okay okay but but but then someone asks
you oh oh could we include this new
column we have Upstream so we can add it
in the group by
key right and you're like I mean sure
you
know you you look at the com history
this you know you find them in the wild
it's like completely honest work other
honest is ER work but like you someone
just built it in 10 days right and then
not a single test in there it's working
it's working but but you're you are you
have a time basically initially
initially the testing for this person
that built it right it's a Time sync
it's like I don't have a maintenance
plan in the future so why should I worry
about this this thing but tests in
general are like a design tool for you
right the like the more you you learn
about this kind of environment the more
you realize that that that testable code
is almost welld designed code so
testable data pipelines are are welld
designed data pipelines but hey
sometimes you just inherit stuff right
so what do you do for legacy pipelines
this I like couple more but this is like
like I guess that your insurance policy
when you're when you're just you know
doing the initial changes so so the
first thing you want to do you're going
to run the prod pipeline right you're
going to capture these things called
stable inputs so you're going to run an
end to endend characterization test
build it you're going to build an end to
end characterization test so you're
going to hijack the inje to sample just
enough maybe 10% and you're going to
compare the stats of that 10% to the
100% right ratios of unique values
averages if you you know is money is not
a problem you make a full snapshot of
the of the input data set for just you
know whatever time scale we're talking
about for for hourly daily
weekly you got to find data pipelines
that are the ingestion step is sprinkled
over the data pipeline so we ingest a
little bit on step one we inest a little
bit on step five so that you know you
it's a yeah so you need to set from The
Source data sets directly there so you
create this this this read only stable
inputs next thing you're going to do
you're going to try to generate stable
output stable output you're going to
find all the places that right that
touch external systems that try to
disable them right if you again if you
can do it you change the
credentials and you disable the
networking right dis you do not trust
the data pipeline yet you just disable
the networking on this thing if you
can't sometimes you can't right and then
you fire up a debuger you find
everything that looks like insert delete
truncate copy do com write do update do
delete do rep anything that looks like
has a side effect you try to to mark it
and and disable it right so you're going
to need some infrastructure to do that
then you check the stats for the same
day between the stable output and the
and the r one right now you want to
automate this right you make the data
pipeline read the stable input process
the stable input generate the output in
a test location and then compare the
stable output with the test output and
make sure that they
match right so you make that an end to
end characterization test that will you
know might take you a week might take
you two weeks depending on complexity of
the pipeline but it's but you're going
to run that on every comment every time
you change something right you and then
the first changes that you want to make
as you're kind of familiarizing yourself
with this code base you just want to do
structural changes so you really want to
separate between structural and
behavioral changes structural changes
refactoring moving methods renaming
things extract method inlining a method
fine right you do that you and then you
rerun your end to end characterization
test right something breaks you reverse
and then you you you breathe a little
bit so K has a good line about it is
like make the change easy and make the
easy
change
the a couple couple more okay so about
as data management right we have um you
know once you get into this world right
we just talked about how do you generate
this data so you have you have a
spectrum right you have static data
preparation versus Dynamic data
preparation
on the static data preparation
side it's
basically um you know a developer comes
to you and tells you tells you hey why
can can we just make a copy of the
database uh or increase the resources on
this database so I can run I'm not sure
if this alter statement I'm not sure how
long it's going to lock the database
might lock it for 30 seconds might lock
it for a whole day not sure what do we
do there you know so you you naturally
have have um a reason to think about
this test data management so on the
static side right
you you they're useful for complex logic
tests do you have a data frame and
you're changing something you're
calculating something you're generating
new
columns very very kind of
isolated uh tests very good you can
pre-generate the test data it makes your
test Suite run faster right but then as
soon as you generate the static data set
it's it's stale already right as like as
soon the data that you're going to see
next week is already moving so your new
Fields new new uh the number of unique
values like the strings the encoding of
the strings might change so that's the
drawbacks of static data preperation
none of them are are better than the
other you're going to need to use both
if you ever you know jump in this in
this world on the dynamic data
preparation you're going to have um you
know it avoids data drifts right so
we've all done it this is this is a
select from table limit 10 right so you
select from a table you only get 10 rows
back 1 th000 rows back as much as you
can wait for that's Dynamic it's a
generation from from today's
data problem there is that you're going
to wait for the resources sometimes the
production database is going through
maintenance you can't access it at all
sometimes you're competing with
production jobs that are actually trying
to do real
work and uh and there is no reuse on the
static side you generate one but here
you're not going to generate you know
you're not going to be able to reuse the
same data unless you think about how to
do with in your tests
right also if you have larger tests that
need to you know copy some parts of the
databases or files or file system and
put it in some test locations that can
get costly so you need to be able to
like refresh it and delete
it you know carefully without deleting
the production that is right so
credential management there if self.
testing equals true you know you want to
really be
careful if self testing not real it
happens it happens
right sometimes you want to check you
know strings do they have underscore
test do they have death just additional
checks before before doing this like
destructive operations like cleaning up
existing test data sounds trivial right
it's just yeah but so in the modern kind
of
data data warehousing world right you
find I guess like
supporting some most of people know
about this problem so I'm glad right
it's like you have these three types of
of supporting pattern for your testing
so you might not never have asked about
it for your data sources but your data
sources modern ones they do have
something like like a copy and a clone
and a snapshot right so you
snapshot is basically what you want I
just want so we got a report yesterday
about a datab
buug and I don't want to
overwrite the the
data because if I and and to do that I
need to store a snapshot of the of that
bad data so I can do a deeper Deep dive
maybe write a post for my
stakeholders so the snapshot is that
idea of like I want to take a snap of
this table snapshot of this
folder and make it immutable so I don't
want to touch it that's like the easiest
one to to kind of explain and understand
right so the the you know the magic
of of newer data data platforms is that
the storage you only get charged for the
difference between what's in the real
database and what's in your
snapshot some of them also like I have
yes yes SS for time travel but you know
it's it's kind of a little bit of a joke
but time travel I guess appeared maybe
like 10 20 years ago right at the
beginning of computing someone on I
don't even know some you know the
original databases came up with time
travel I want to select from this table
at a specific date and magically the the
query engine is going to be able to tell
you what were the values at that
specific time right so that that time
travel is pretty is pretty good when
you're paying for it obviously there is
a look back configurable but usually set
sometimes you can't even change it so
you might need to combine snapshotting
with something
else now the Clone is uh is the other uh
kind of it's it's basically your fork in
your database in a completely different
table name name for
example and it's it stays mutable so you
can you know you have your alter
statements your inserts some some fixing
that you have to do from your data
Pipeline and the Clone will allow you
to like change and change the existing
data set and any new data set that
you're
generating without messing with the I
guess the master branch of your data
right so that's something to ask your
dpas your your file system admins your
storage layer folks hey do we support
cloning maybe yes maybe no who knows
copy I
mean now that you know about cloning and
snapshotting copy is like your last
resource right I'm just going to make a
copy sometimes it's not possible
sometimes it is but you know depending
on the resources you have so just you
know go go home go go to work and ask
about clones and snapshots I have a
couple more examples about kind of
topics um so yeah so testing in general
building tests for data pipelines is
quite
um you know they they protect your
stakeholders but also they protect your
time right and and a big deal for
developer time and productivity is what
you can do from your laptop from your
laptop you should be able to run the
unit test run integration test run some
sort of endtoend tests either on your
laptop or like your development
environment you should be able to build
unit test CI environment and deploy and
you should be able to release two pro
how does it look like for a data
engineer for data
engineering you want to right you start
your work right okay okay you have a
notebook okay good so you have a
notebook you have a query editor
whatever you use for query
editors you want to upgrade yourself to
IDs little intellisense little
navigation little refractor
in nice right you want data explorers
where I generate these files I generate
these things I want to click on the
files right they're not tables but I
want to click on want to see the inside
of those files maybe get a preview
right you want Direct Read only access
to fraud CU why not maybe sometimes
right access to some fraud that you're
only the owner of you know why not and
then you want something you know in the
future you know modernization uh effort
you want self-service platform right I
want dedicated on demand death T stage
infrastructure of the
service
provisioning right you want I'm going to
I want spin up you know I'm creating
this this table or this folder for
consumption I want to create a test for
it test table test folder I should be
able to do that I have a topic I want to
create a test topic I have a database I
want to create a test
database all the components job cues
maybe they're managed by someone else
but I want a Dev CU I want a ciq in my
in my class right I want to be able to
publish metrics obviously and for story
systems you know I want to have maybe
you know there's Kota fine but
definitely I want to be able to read and
write from my
development so this autonomous sorts of
data devs sometimes get forgotten oh I'm
just going to write my unit test on my
laptop that's that's the beginning right
when you're thinking about
infrastructure you need to do this sort
of large scale data pipelines
testing you will hit this these problems
right away you're like yeah creating the
underscore test anything you create
something you want underscore test with
it next next thing uh designing for
tability right so this
is so you probably do this already if
you haven't done it you know you should
that's think it's nice decoupling
temporarily
decouple right you historical data
feature engineering training model
inference with a schedule workflow and
then you have production
consumer that's step one right
everything in one script one app end to
end run like a story 15 Steps okay okay
that's your starting point right okay
what you want is use the ideas from
continuous delivery big one is artifact
repository where you are constantly you
can iterate your pieces of your pipeline
and and publish various uh artifacts
which will be used by the next
steps it increases a little bit the
complexity but now the feature
engineering component can be tested in
isolation without having to wait for a
model to
train so that's you want to keep this I
have a couple kind other examples not
for today but you can you can uh you can
imagine there is patterns that people
came up with and you might not be aware
them I mean I wasn't aware of them for
sure for sure but as I as I researched
this thing I think it's useful it's
useful uh data organization take this
scorecard this is this is last just you
know take this scorecard right this
honest data Dev is like he's primarily
here for the paycheck you know he's
supporting his family but he's also like
a you know honest guy he's do all the
good work but what do I care about
governance you know you have a scaleter
here sound like a VP kind of thing see
you in four to five eight weeks above my
pay grade I'll do my best and I got this
so the darker you get the more it's like
data Dev is like yeah of course you know
I'll do it of course it's my job yeah so
processing activation of data fine you
know it's my
job workflows yeah I think someone else
should be managing the workflow thing
collection of the data well it's there
who I don't know where it came from
exploration that's someone else's job
cicd like why are you asking me this it
work on my laptop it's fine it's fine
everybody authorization security
operations uh sharing data with teams a
little less of of an like concern for
the data then governance uh like it
should like I guess some data devs will
be interesting is some
not but at least you learn about the
vocabulary so that you can uh so take
this sheet I'm I'm curious if you ever
uh you
know where do you where do you grade
them in your day-to-day job have a
couple tips and stuff like that but
that's it for me I have um you know just
yeah it's good uh yeah so I I I try to
compile all of these kind of ideas in
one in one write up modern data P
testing techniques you know it's useful
use it if it's not just burn it got to
say it's pretty much it
[Applause]
thank